WHAT'S THE LAST THING YOU'D
EXPECT KIM KARDASHIAN TO REVEAL?
THAT SHE'S STUDYING TO BECOME A
LAWYER.
THAT'S RIGHT, KHLOE KARDASHIAN'S
SISTER IS APPRENTICING AT A LAW
FIRM, LIKELY CONTRIBUTED BY HER
ADVISEMENT OF THE 63-YEAR-OLD
WOMAN JAILED FOR YEARS ON
NON-VIOLENT CHARGES.
WHY NOT?
IF THIS PERSON CAN BECOME A
LAWYER, AND THIS PERSON CAN
BECOME A LAWYER, AND THIS PERSON
CAN BECOME A LAWYER, AND I SAY
PERSON LOOSELY, WHY CAN'T KIM?
SHE'S GOT MORE SENSE THAN ALL OF
THEM COMBINED.
AVENATTI JUST GOT HIS $5 MILLION
JET CONFISCATED.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
LAWYERS GET AWAY WITH EVERYTHING
BECAUSE THEY KNOW HOW TO GET
AROUND EVERYTHING.
AVENATTI ONLY GOT CAUGHT BECAUSE
THE MEDIA'S ROACH MOTEL DREW HIM
OUT OF THE NOOX AN
OUT OF THE NOOKSAN
OUT OF THE NOOKS AND CRANNIES
WHERE HE DID HIS DIRTY WORK.
WE SHOULD ALL BECOME LAWYERS.
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT LIFE,
IT'S BASICALLY A GAME OF
MONOPOLY AND LAWYERS ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO WRITE THE
INSTRUCTIONS AND ACTUALLY TAKE A
FEW MINUTES TO READ THEM.
WITHOUT A LAW DEGREE, WE'RE JUST
SAPS.
INSTEAD OF KNOCKING KIM FOR
BRINGING A LITTLE BOOM-BOOM TO
THE COURTROOM, WE SHOULD FOLLOW
HER LEAD AND LET HER REST HER
CASE WHEREVER SHE WANTS.
EMILY, YOU CLAIM TO BE A LAWYER.
I DON'T DOUBT IT FOR ONE SECOND.
YOU TALK LIKE A LAWYER.
VERY FAST.
YOU READ EVERYTHING, THE SMALL
PRINT.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
WORLD.
I'M SCARED OF YOU.
>> OKAY.
ON THIS --
>> THAT WASN'T A QUESTION.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I THINK WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT
HER REASONING FOR THIS -- AND
FIRST OF ALL, SHE'S NOT GOING TO
LAW SCHOOL.
SHE'S UNDERTAKING A FOUR-YEAR
APPRENTICESHIP WITH THE LAW
FIRM.
SHE TAKES A MINI BAR EXAM.
IF SHE PASSES, SHE'S ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE.
HER STATEMENT, IF I KNEW MORE, I
COULD DO MORE.
>> IF I KNEW MORE, I COULD DO
MORE?
THAT IS HER STATEMENT?
>> I WONDER HOWEVER IF BEING AN
ATTORNEY IS THAT.
I THINK SOMEBODY WITH MILLIONS
OF FOLLOWERS WHO IS LITERALLY
THE INFLUENCER OF THE CENTURY
FOR EVERYONE ELSE, YOU KNOW, BUT
PEOPLE AT THIS TABLE, THEN I
THINK MAYBE SHE COULD DO MORE
WITH HER ATTENTION RATHER --
WERE ON THE ATTENTION ON HER.
>> BUT IF SHE KNEW LESS, THEN
SHE WOULD DRESS LESS.
I DON'T KNOW.
JUAN, THOUGHTS?
>> IF SHE KNEW LESS, SHE WOULD
DRESS LESS?
I WOULD SAY SHE'S DISTRACTING IN
THE COURTROOM.
I -- THIS TO ME IS LIKE AMATEUR
HOUR.
SHE SAID SHE WAS IN -- I THINK
IT WAS THE ROOSEVELT ROOM AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH THE PRESIDENT,
BOY, THESE PEOPLE ARE MAKING --
I WANT TO KNOW MORE.
TO ME, IT'S VERY JUVENILE.
YOU KNOW WHAT, SHE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO STICK IT THROUGH.
AS YOU SAID, A FOUR-YEAR DEAL.
YOU KNOW WHAT, LET'S LOOK AT THE
POSITIVE SIDE.
AS YOU SAID, EMILY, SHE'S VERY
INFLUENTIAL WITH YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HOLD HER UP, WHO ADMIRE HER.
CLEARLY SHE'S MORPHED INTO
SOMEBODY WHO SAYS I WANT TO DO
MORE WITH MY LIFE, I REALLY WANT
TO HAVE IMPACT ON AMERICA AND
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
GO, GIRL.
YOU GOT IT.
>> WHEN YOU'RE AROUND A GOOD
LAWYER, IT'S A SUPER POWER.
IT'S LIKE THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
STUFF YOU DON'T.
>> AND YOU'RE GOING TO NEED ONE.
>> YES.
>> YOU NEED A GOOD LAWYER IN
YOUR LIFE.
LAW SCHOOL I'VE HEARD IS LIKE
TAKING THREE FOREIGN LANGUAGES
AT THE SAME TIME.
I WOULD ADD ONE THING.
>> WHAT?
>> IF SHE KNEW HOW, SHE WOULD
HAVE MORE WOW.
>> THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
JESSE, WOULDN'T THE SOLUTION BE
TO TEACH LAW IN GRADE SCHOOL?
>> I CAN'T GET OVER HER
STATEMENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IF I KNEW MORE, I WOULD DO MORE?
>> SHE'S TRYING.
YOU THINK KNOWING MORE IS
OVERRATED.
>> NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> MY FAVORITE IS WHEN JESSE
GETS TEARS IN HIS EYES.
>> WHAT'S HER HOURLY RATE?